hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host
grace helbig today we have aaron hanson
with us
or as you might know him half of the
gaming
animation channel game grumps you might
know
him from creating dream daddy a dad
dating simulator
or their most recent game soviet jump
game
two very different games uh appropriate
for a very complex interesting artist
that is aaron
we learn about his love for dance and
his mother's healing horse therapy
center
there's a lot to unpack in this episode
i had a wonderful conversation
with aaron and i hope you enjoy it as
much as i did
[Music]
aaron thank you for being here wow thank
you for having me
this is very cool i get to see people
finally after five months
i know i was gonna ask how are you doing
but i also feel like
right now that's a very loaded question
to ask people because
it's like do we really want the answers
for how people are doing
man it's all over the map i have some
friends that are like dude i've never
been more creatively satisfied in my
life
and i have other people who are like i
wish i were dead right now yeah
no i agree those are the two ends of the
spectrum and uh there's no in between
but also for someone like you who does
12 000 things at the same time
i'm sure this situation must feel a
little uh
complicated because you have nothing but
time now to work on these 12 000 things
but then you have nothing but time to
work on these 12 000 things
yeah exactly i'm trying i'm trying to
focus on like the self-care stuff
you know like let's get a little bit
deeper into meditation
and like take care of my body losing
weight and stuff so
nice it's mostly that stuff it's it's
weird
there's like a total creative i don't
know my brain just wants to be in
different
spaces and when i'm in the same space
all the time
it's it's sort of creates like a
creative damper and i don't like
feel super creative although doing the
show that we do game grumps regularly
has been a huge
it's been nice to have something that's
like regular and it's like okay every
monday
totally and it's a thing well this is my
friend dan
okay i to people that have no idea who
you are and what you do
but when i talk to someone that wears
many hats does many things
i like to ask them what is your deal how
do you describe what your deal is to
someone that you've just met for the
first time
oh man i hate to put you on the spot but
yeah well yeah it's like it's like i
have to imagine myself in the back of an
uber right
right yeah having polite conversation
until you get to your destination
yeah um i usually try i usually start by
saying i'm a comedian
um which which is technically true
um but then i have to elaborate and say
like you know i mostly do a youtube show
um
and then you know then it gets into oh
okay what is it about it's a gaming show
i have a comedy partner and we do this
show where we play games every day and
um just be funny over it
as as best of our abilities and uh
we're not very good at the games i think
that's probably something that people
need to be prefaced with if they're
going to check us out
we're not like ninja where we're kicking
ass at every game we're
right we're kind of fumbling through
everything you're much more realistic in
your game play
i find as someone who is truly
awful at every game that i've ever
played
um and really
understands fundamentally like how you
can get good at a game but like
has never followed through to get to
that space
uh do you
purposely try to stay bad at the games
you
play no i mean there are some places
where
where i practiced beforehand just
because i knew it was going to be an
ordeal if i didn't if i wasn't that good
at it
um but there's i don't feel like there's
ever been a point where i'm like
dude i'm amazing at this game unless
it's like
for the bit right right it's like if if
i come in and i'm like mediocre at the
game
and i'm like dude this is gonna i'm
gonna blow your minds and then i just
die all the time then that's kind of
funny yeah but yeah
i'm never i'm never like the master at
anything
so okay walk us through because i'm
fascinated with the world of gaming on
youtube it's massive
it's complex it's interesting but it
also is so foreign to me
uh when you started game grumps
or game game yeah game grumps right i'm
saying that right yeah
okay for some reason i thought it was
game gumps for a second i was like uh
how did you start that did you see this
happening on youtube or did you just
kind of play
like innocently and then like
organically fold it into the youtube
situation yeah i mean it was sort of
it did start kind of ironically because
i was doing um
i was doing cartoons mostly on youtube
which at the time that i was doing that
which was like
you know eight years ago um youtube
functioned a little differently and you
know you could put out a one minute
video
and that would be like your jam for the
month yeah um
but uh you know quickly things changed
and luckily i had already started game
grumps
at that point but um even before then
it was just something to do on the side
that was fun you know get together every
week
um we we had a regimen where it was
literally like
we would get together we'd record
episodes we'd edit the episodes
on that day and then just and then that
was it
for the rest of the week and then we
would just put them up every day because
you couldn't schedule uploads back then
right right right
how archaic of us so so strange right
so your video went up at 1101 what oh my
god
um but uh
quickly we found out that you know we we
had garnered a pretty decent fan base
like right away because
it was kind of a super group of sorts
like we both
started from uh channels that we had on
our own and came together and did this
thing so
um it was it was already like oh this
could be a thing um and so like over the
course of a year
it went from a side project to like okay
this is the thing
um because it was very fulfilling it was
very fun i mean it's like
getting together and playing video games
there's nothing better than that really
yeah uh you're hanging out continuing to
grow the
yeah exactly and and trying to make each
other laugh as much as possible
um but then you know as as it sort of
started to grow and get more of a fan
base it was like what else can we do
with this can we
you know make other shows can we um use
some of our abilities instead you know
um a year into the show we got
my current co-host dan who's a singer so
like
we in in a band called ninja sex parties
so like
we collaborated on a music thing called
star bomb and
so it's like it was like what what else
can we do in this space
that that will sort of like um be
creatively fulfilling for us
that's awesome and so now you work with
dan how i'm curious when you
find a partner to play video games with
what's the process in like vetting
if they're going to be fun to play with
is it like speed dating
is it like uh like internet dating it
feels like you have to have great
chemistry
and do you try it out and see if you're
both into it
so we were dan and i before he was on
the show
um we were working on a song together
right um and as we were like
coming up with more ideas for songs and
coming up with song titles
one night at like 3am or whatever we
were just totally cracking each other up
and like i hadn't laughed that hard just
from like one other person interacting
in like so long
that there was there was just i was like
man
you know if i ever needed like another
co-host for something this would be the
guy
and uh you know it it came to be that
like you know a year in it was like oh i
think we do need a new co-host and
he was just the first pick like bar none
it
sounds very romantic to me to be very
honest
uh it feels like a love connection
people do like to like to do and you
know we yeah
a little bit is there a level of like
fan fiction shipping
happening between you guys dude so much
i mean look okay i'm learning all this
stuff about you i've been watching all
of these interviews with you i've been
learning a lot about your life
um so i'm sorry if i seem like a stalker
but that makes sense if you have like
the dream daddy
game that comes out first i feel like
there's uh there's a lot of love
inspired in that game
uh yes i also think it's interesting
that you guys met through
music so do music and gaming go
together do you find that the audience
kind of crosses over for both
uh areas um i mean that's
this sort of goes back to how uh what we
talked about at the beginning is when i
say like what i am i say i'm a comedian
right so
um you know i would i would i would look
at somebody like uh
like a shroud or whatever it's like
that's a gaming streamer you know like
but i don't consider myself first and
foremost like a gaming youtuber
um i would say the comedy comes first
and then the gaming is like the vessel
uh so when i look at it like that you
know
dan came from a comedy music background
yeah um
so it's sort of it's sort of meshed
really well and he's quick and he has
improv
experience and stuff um so it was it was
sort of more or that
and um and then it became kind of funny
that the dynamic was
you know he's a little older than i am
so we come from like a different like a
slightly
different generation of gaming um
so like i have experience here and then
he has experience here
so sort of seeing like when i come in
and i'm like dude this is awesome and
he's like i don't know what's going on
and then when he's like this is my jam
and i'm like
wow this is really bringing it back yeah
yeah there's something to learn from
each other it feels like yeah then
there's then there's that perfect
dynamic and then also like as we go on
we see what the fans like
latched on to and stuff like for example
i'm i played
sonic games all the time sonic the
hedgehog and like i have this weird
love-hate relationship with sonic the
hedgehog and
you know when people watch that it's
just very amazing in a way
a lot of people have that have you seen
the movie
i i regrettably have not even though
i am probably entrenched in that world i
have seen the movie and you are not
missing anything
you're uh you'd save your money you're
good
oh no it's uh it's one of those
you wish it was better than it was and
you knew it could have been better than
it was
oh yeah still i i'm glad that the
internet
audience created a new sense of
animation for it i think that's
helpful um speaking of animation you're
involved in
animation you're involved in voice over
you're involved in music you're involved
in game play uh how have you seen
because i've talked to alex clark about
this on podcasts before
the animation community on youtube seems
to be
growing and thriving in a way that as an
outsider is
cool to watch what's your point of view
on that because there's so much work
that goes into creating
animated pieces to make it look
effortless i think that's still
something that a lot of people forget
like how many
hours it takes you to produce a piece of
content
yeah i i mean that's that's the real
thing right like
animation there's there's no there's no
like cheat for animation right like
yeah it's just gonna take a long time um
i i i think what's interesting about the
animation sphere
which i guess is true for most things on
youtube but like
it was very algorithmically driven you
know um
like i said when i started i did you
know a minute and minute and a half
shorts and that was
enough um but but then when there was a
huge shift in algorithm to be about like
regular content daily content long form
content
um there wasn't really a space
for that kind of stuff anymore but then
there were sort of the new kids on the
block that came around like the jaden
animations and the odd ones out of the
world
where they were like we can do this sort
of like limited style
but make the videos longer and i don't
know if that was like a conscious effort
to to appeal to the algorithm or
whatever but like that was sensational
like right out the gate it was like
boom this hits all the ticks and it
still has that sort of animation appeal
um so i think that's why we're seeing a
lot more animation pop up
and then also it seems as if
things are shifting again because i've
seen dudes like
like bird and stuff who make like six
second animations and they get like
millions of views
um you know i don't i don't know in
terms of like
monetization or whatever how like
lucrative that is but sure
though those things are getting out
there as well and getting a lot more
attention again
um so i think with things like patreon
and stuff those things are a lot more
viable
because then people can just be like hey
i'll just throw you a couple bucks and
you can make a living off of this
right right right i mean there it's it's
fascinating it's also fun to hear
everyone's
um handles so casually said because they
i don't know
any of these people and so to hear you
just throw out these names that sound
like the fantasy fiction characters i'm
like yes bird of course
yeah so stefanos 328 is one of my
favorite animators of all time
yeah i'm like that sounds like an
antidepressant but
sounds great uh okay
let's talk about music so music's always
been
in your blood music's been something
you've done since you were young
yeah well i mean that's that's the weird
thing right is everyone
talks about like you know we talk about
animation or whatever people say like
going back to my roots and it's like
yeah i did animation like eight years
ago before that
i was just a creative kid i was just i
was drawing i was
writing music i was writing poetry i was
like you were an artist
yeah whatever i could to just get the
energy out right yeah
and animation was the the first thing
that sort of paid because
um i got contacted by mtv because of one
animation that i made on online is that
true
you got contacted by mtv did they how
did they reach out to you
they're like hello we are mtv and we
would like to pay you
to do your thing i mean pretty much like
i
you know he sent me an email and he was
like let's talk on the phone and
um so you know and i had only put out
i'd only put out like one
cartoon it was just it was that sort of
sensational and that sort of small
sphere on newgrounds.com so
um you know he saw that he was like i
want that for mtv i just want little 30
second interstitial
bits um and like the pay was garbage but
it was like oh my god i'm working for
mtv
yeah i'm a paid artist that doesn't
happen for people
yeah exactly so i it was just it was
sort of validation it was like oh this
could be something
finally um and then that's why i sort of
leaned into it
after that that sort of contract was
over it was like why don't i just keep
doing this
um and then youtube came along with
monetization and that was
like the first time i was really making
a living off of it um
what was the dang question oh music but
along the way
music has been in the background this
has been something that you've been
doing
and you said uh so you and dan started
starbomb
yes that's correct dan his musical
partner brian who they do ninja sex
party together
and and me that was sort of like the it
originally started as just one song i
just had an idea for a song and i was
like
who else to collaborate with than my
friends who have a band
um and then we made the song and we
recorded the song
and after like we were literally in the
booth recording that song and we were
just like
that was really fun should we do another
one and
and they're like yeah yeah
pretty much and then after the second
one we were like i think we could
probably do a whole album of this
can we do an album yeah so i don't
know it really is like you're building a
relationship with each other they're
like should we go on the second date i
guess
but then uh you know we we did the the
first album and i did
the sort of like debut music video that
was sort of like my
my coming back to animation i guess like
people were very stoked that like after
a year or two i
i put out an animation that i made um
and uh
it was just you know it was way bigger
than we expected it to be
cool and so so we did two more albums
after that
that's awesome and and you've also
toured you've done
lots of like live uh events and things
like that
which i bet for animators uh
and artists like you're probably seen as
like a low-key
like introverted kind of person that to
be able to go out on stage and do music
is an entirely different like
emotional persona to put on do you feel
like when you perform music
that you become a different person or is
it just kind of you on stage take it or
leave it
i love performing in front of a live
audience it's
so fun addictive dude feeling that
energy
of this i mean that's why we that's a
lot of the reason why we started
our touring company real good touring
was it was just like
we we loved the like feeling of being on
stage and like
that energy and stuff and the the back
end of it was so
like gross like everyone that we
worked with um when we were starting out
was just sort of like sort of in it to
take advantage of us
um so we were like why don't we just
start a company that's like focused on
the fun of it
and like you know the bus composition
like what it's like to be on a bus with
people and like
pick the right people for that and just
make it plan days off so people can like
have fun in a cool town that they've
never been in
um and so when we when we sort of did
like the test run of our company with
game grumps that was like
this is the most fun i've ever had in my
life and like now we've gone to europe
and
um you know once this is all over we're
planning to go to like australia and do
some more international stuff
cool yeah i was gonna ask if there's
plans in the future once
everything returns to whatever it's
gonna be
yeah it's a little slow right now i will
admit um
yeah we uh we call it the uh on our show
uh i don't have you heard the backstreet
boys reunion tour thing
uh no okay so we
at the at the very beginning of all this
stuff going on with the pandemic and
everything
there was there was a rumor going around
that youtube was demonetizing videos
that
said coronavirus and pandemic and stuff
so um when we started recording during
that time
we instead were like the backstreet boys
reunion tour is going on
like wild now and getting tickets
to the backstreet boys reunion tour uh
so don't go out and get i know it's
tempting
to go out and get those tickets they're
everywhere
you can't you can't go anywhere without
seeing those tickets
oh that's amazing i love that uh
very very much um also i feel like
in that same sense that there is a world
in which you guys could collaborate with
the backstreet boys and do a live tour
together
once everything has returned to normal i
i
i don't know if i hope to god or really
hope not that they've heard that
because and it was and it was there was
something
there was something so uh surreal about
the fact that
they actually were planning on doing a
reunion
during this time and they cancelled it
my friend went to one of their pop-up
shows
in los angeles and she said it was very
poorly attended and she had a great time
i don't know that's how i was like what
about the reunion tour what you got
what's the dish
what's going on uh that's
incredible okay we're gonna take a quick
break uh when we get back
i wanna know about you your um your
mother's healing horse therapy center
i wanna know about everything that
you've been up to
in quarantine and i also need to know
about this dance reality show that you
were on many many moons ago
a big time okay we'll be right back with
more not too deep
[Music]
hey guys we're taking a break from the
podcast real quick to do
some promotion of ourselves
that's right yes we are promoting
ourselves little reminder to you guys
out there
that if you go into the apple podcast
and you rate and review
not too deep it's a beautiful wonderful
helpful thing for us and for you guys it
helps people
find our podcast that helps us hear what
you guys like what you don't like etc
and we just appreciate you taking the
time again
uh go to apple podcast leave us a rating
review whatever you want
aaron um let's talk about
old school youtube you're on a dance
reality competition show that's that's
right it was dance showdown
dance showdown i watched this show
when it aired uh my friend really my
friend hannah hart was on it
and she did oh damn she did a dance
about
shoes and having too many shoes in her
closet
and it it's my favorite thing to show
her because she's so embarrassed to this
day
uh about that how was your experience
on this program you know i um
that wasn't my first reality show i did
one
before that called the tester which was
like you know it was it was this sort of
[Music]
niche uh about playstation
and like competing to become a
playstation tester or something
which was more sense for your brand that
you were building at the time
yeah but even even then it was it was
sort of like a joke that i was
going on they made you enter like a
popularity contest and so i was
all over youtube and like vote for me
vote for me
and oh yeah i did the king of the web
thing
that happened years and years and years
ago same context same
content like please vote for me that's
all yeah
um i i had a very negative experience
with
i met a lot of very cool people um on
the tester
you know most of the contestants were
awesome a lot of the crew was awesome
um but just like the whole experience of
like having all the footage cut up and
you know the narrative like driven to
make me look like an [ __ ]
oh yeah and as someone that is building
your own content by yourself
you are the master in command of
everything that you're doing to
relinquish that control to
a producer and editor of a show that you
have no uh
say in must have been wild yeah yeah it
was it was pretty strange to say the
least um
and there was there were so many moments
where i was like that's not how i
reacted to that they just used a
different shot
i was actually smiling when they said
that
um but dan's showdown was just
my whole life i'd always wanted to dance
and i never really
like got into yeah like i love music
and i don't know there's just something
you know i watch dance videos all the
time and i think they're awesome
um so they actually reached out to me
and was like do you want to do this and
i was like yeah i kind of do
um so they so they brought me in and uh
that was actually a very positive
experience and i think i think based on
my experience
with reality shows in general i was sort
of
able to shape how they um
interacted with me because you know
when i did the first show i didn't
really know the boundaries and like what
i was capable of
sort of demanding with my actions but on
dan's showdown i was like straight away
you know they were trying to create
because i had a
my dance teacher um her name was maxine
who's
very pretty and very talented right so
from the get-go they were trying to
force this sort of narrative that i was
like very attracted to her
and like from the very beginning i was
like i'm not playing this game dude no
i'm not gonna give you any fuel for this
yeah um so they were like okay okay like
i remember very strictly there was a
point where they were like all right
let's move on like
i was like cool spicy spice okay cool
cool
um do you still dance is dance still
something that you
want to add into the 17 billion things
that you have going on
uh it is yeah i like i still have a very
big interest in it um
it's it's if it's anything it's a hobby
um and it's just a matter of like
sitting down and actually doing it
because that's the thing is like
nowadays if i have free time i either
sleep
or i read or i work on some project
you know or spend time with my wife like
yeah
hobbies are so few far in between now um
except that i've gotten really into
magic to gathering but that's a whole
nother
there you go but i have a feeling you're
going to figure out how to monetize that
very quickly i already did actually
open up a card channel
you can't be stopped you have to have
something just for you
i know i know well it was it was a waste
it was getting out of control the hobby
was getting out of control so i was
trying to find a way to like
pay for it there you go and then and
then of course it because like i love
this like of course i want to share this
with an audience like this is great
that's wonderful um speaking of things
that you share with an audience
uh you have launched games which
i can't imagine the amount of work that
goes into something like that
seems like a very easy thing to say that
you've done
but i'm sure it's a extremely
complicated
complex beast to try and tame uh
the first one was dream daddy a dad
dating simulator
yeah and for people that aren't familiar
how do you describe that
um it is a game where you play as
a hot gay dad and you are trying to
romance other hot gay dads in your
neighborhood
it's what we've all been craving for
years
as uh that's what it is on the surface
but it really is
it enveloped in it is this very
wholesome story about family
and like raising a kid i mean it sounds
amazing i'm
i in learning about this and learning
about you before this interview i
i'm i'm sad that it's only now that i'm
learning about
this game uh how did the conversation
about this game even begin
um well so i've you know my whole life
i've sort of been told no
about like creative endeavors and stuff
um so that's sort of why
i carved my own path and something like
youtube was so
um enticing was because it was just like
i could just make what i want put it out
there
so that's sort of the mantra that i've
wanted
that that i've tried to have with game
grumps
so you know we hire people at game
grumps to do a specific job
but you know if they have an idea or
they have a concept that they want to
run with
and you know i always say as long as
somebody's spearheading something like
it'll end up getting done um
and vernon who was hired on as a
producer for the show aspect of it
came to me and just pitched gave me the
elevator pitch for dream daddy and
you know i i loved it and like he's like
he's a
he's a nervous dude um so
to have him like stick his neck out and
be like i really want to spend
resources on this and time and like your
money on this project like
i'm pitching this to you yeah it was
like wow
he cares a lot about this enough to like
put his
non-confrontationalness aside and um
so i was like yes of course um and then
we just built the team from there like
none of us had made a game before it was
our first game and
um so we just sort of recruited people
who knew what they were doing better
than us
and collaborated fully through the whole
process and it ended up being
this sensation that we had no i mean we
were happy to
break even but the fact that it did as
well as it did was
monumental that's awesome so how
how long did it take you to develop that
game
i believe that was about a year of
development
wow um and that was from the ground up
we built that engine
um i know there's engines out there for
for dating sims or whatever but we built
everything from scratch
in that game i mean it's it's very
impressive and now
you have a new game soviet jump game
that's right
um a little bit of a departure from the
gay dad dating game
so take me through this development
process
well so that was um that was after dream
daddy
um you know when we had like sort of
made a name for ourselves as
you know a producer uh we started
getting pitches from people
and uh for the most part it was just
like you know no we're not
we're not like a big producer like we
did dream daddy because it was a passion
project
and you know it was it was sort of
like a in terms of like budget it was
very very bare bones it was a very cheap
game
um and so you know we're getting pitches
from people that are like you know we
need two million dollars or whatever and
we're like oh
i don't know about that buddy record
player scratch
yeah but then but then we had a dude who
you know i had played his game in the
past he made a game called strafe his
name is tom
um and uh i so i knew he had the chops
and he came to us and it was it was a
very like it was a very
simple cheap concept that was like
you know this is a battle royale
inspired by 2d platformers
um and that's that's something that we
sort of value a lot of game grumps is
like this
this idea that you can um
like what's the word compress an idea to
like you know is
if you can compress an idea down to like
the fewest amount of words
like really simplify it yeah then it has
then it has traction right and then it's
very appealing
um so the fact that i can tell you that
dream daddy a bad dating simulator
is you play a hot gay dad and you're
trying to romance other hockey dads
right like that's
you have to have that quick elevator
pitch for it that
sums everything up yeah so this was like
a 2d platformer love letter in a battle
royale format and it's like
nobody's done that yet this is a great
concept you know the art was amazing
um and we we came up with this whole
narrative of releasing it about how it's
this old dendi game that we found
um so it was it just felt like
the perfect fit that we really liked tom
as a partner
and so we just went full steam ahead on
that that's awesome and so it's is this
officially
out and available now or is it yes it
was in early access for
quite a long time because we were um you
know building up the player base
um and uh sort of getting feedback we
were very like
face forward about you know we started a
discord that was basically like come in
we're doing events like play the game
tell us exactly what you think
you know so a lot of the fans i assume
that you rely heavily on
honest feedback from the audience in
that regard
yeah absolutely especially because it's
it's such a heavily multiplayer game
um so having players play all the time
and just
feeding us like i found this bug i
you know i i think this could be better
etcetera etcetera like we were always
listening
to this discord group yeah um and it
ended up making the game
super solid and so the the 1.0 version
it's out of early access it
officially came out um last week
so we're so we're super excited to to
get people playing this game because
it's so
fun congratulations that's uh i i
imagine that's kind of like having a
child
yeah it's any any creative project is a
little bit like
it's like sending them off to college or
so it's like go uh
do well i hope it goes okay
don't let them make fun of you yeah
uh that's wonderful so now it's out in
the world
uh do are you considering more
games or is that kind of uh well play it
by ear as it comes
it it sort of is a little bit i mean we
do have a couple games that are
in development um we really wanted to
give
a lot of the team members of dream daddy
like sort of a chance to pitch their
visions um as long as it was if we were
as we were able to
produce it like be good partners for it
um so we've got a couple stuff in the
works
um that's really all i can say
cool keep it keep it cryptic very fun
uh well congratulations that's awesome
and it's cool to know that people can go
and play it and it's available
and you can still i guess look for bugs
look for problems if you want
let's your mother has a healing horse
therapy center
that's right yeah um so she's uh
i i mean she's incredible she's uh
she's a horse trainer so she's
incredible at um
at taming she she's sort of has this
like miracle horse that was um
that was like this untameable horse that
was just this ruthless relentless horse
that ever
that it was just a problem for everybody
and she ended up taming it and it became
her best
horse oh wow uh and so she opened up
a therapy center for like veterans and
victims of sexual abuse
and special needs people where you know
tending to
and learning to ride horses and just
being around sort of
the the nature of it um is is very
healing
um and i've experienced that firsthand
myself oh they're majestic creatures
they're they're so
like their presence is so uh
overwhelming in a sense absolutely i
mean yeah they're they're huge
and they're and they're beautiful and
they're um
it's so easy to form like a connection
with a horse like so
quickly um especially when you're like
when you're riding them and you have to
you know control
you know how how they're walking and
it's it's this total relationship
where you know you understand the horse
the horse understands you um
so it's it's it's really amazing and i
try i try every year
to um to raise money for my mom's
charity uh
so that she can you know keep the wheels
going on that because it's a completely
pro bono charity you can come in and
yeah there's no like
how cool there's no admission or
anything like that ah and what is uh
what does mom think of the
the creative path that you've taken in
your adult
professional life at this point
she loves it um she's a big fan she
always always gives me feedback on the
certain series that we're doing and
that's uh but she has very specific
tastes i think
she's and she's not afraid to tell me
like that one series you did
i don't like that one that one's not so
great you should stop doing that
oh that's wonderful moms can't help
themselves
that's so great what is it uh what is
her
program called the healing horse therapy
center that's the name that's the
official name of it oh wonderful yeah
well
and it's in florida it's in north
carolina now it was in florida but um
they've moved
very cool very cool okay we're gonna
take one last break when we get back we
have a bunch of very important twitter
questions for you
so we'll be right back with more not too
[Music]
deep
[Music]
okay aaron before we get into these
twitter questions i'm gonna ask you the
two questions
i ask every single guest that is on the
podcast the first
is who alive or dead would you most
like to throw cold spaghetti at
oh i was expecting like get a drink with
and then
through the ball i mean it could be
considered kind of the same thing
if you're both having a great time
because that i mean that that one's got
easy
it's like hitler like way like
the bad ones yes but it can also be seen
as
a a sign of endearment a sign of
celebration
it can also uh yeah be a a sign of
encouragement
depends on the person but so your answer
is hitler
i mean i would do more than throw cold
spaghetti if i had the opportunity
[Laughter]
okay well the other question i ask every
single guest
is to tell us your worst pants [ __ ]
story or
a close call but you can only use three
words or
small phrases so for example mine
is college jogging front lawn
[Music]
it was okay um
uh grumps
screaming wasn't sure
okay i appreciate it i also always
appreciate
when i guest immediately can recall a
story because there are guests that will
go
i've never had that experience and i'm
like oh please
you haven't lived if you're over 28
you've had a pan-shitting story
exactly thank you uh okay
let's get into these twitter questions
they're very important
they're very serious and uh people want
to know some things
so first one what is worse a
mouthful of bees or a butthole filled
with bees
thank you for your time
uh starting off very sincere
uh well bees won't harm you unless
they're provoked so
either is fine with me as long as it is
a
safe interaction so a mouthful and a
butthole
full of bees are both equally okay for
you
i guess a mouthful would probably be
easier just in general
yeah i feel like i would have less
control over the butthole situation
yeah i i agree i think the butthole
situation might be a little bit more
precarious than the
the mouth situation though with the
butthole situation you're still
able to scream so uh i don't know if
that works
so well with the mouth situation i am a
friend to all bees i love bees they're
one of my favorite creatures in
the animal kingdom so i would never
scream with an interaction of bees
go for have you thought about adding on
to the billion things that you're doing
beekeeping why haven't i
actually considered that yet oh i
thought you were going to say like i
actually have a side business in which i
do this already i mean we have a little
bee house
and we you know when we garden we try to
plant stuff
that bees really love oh that's sweet
yeah so they i mean because the you know
bees are always the fr they're fragile
creatures in nature
in terms of like you know are they dying
are they not dying and
so like as much as we can to be like hey
bees come please live and be healthy
we are providing you nourishment exactly
okay next question would he rather
[ __ ] his pants every time he ate fruit
or vomit every time he ate vegetables
another important question
i didn't know the show would be this
blue
we're very democrat
[Laughter]
oh geez i feel like i eat vegetables a
lot more
so the fruit one yeah i'm with you also
i i think vomiting is one of the worst
feelings a body can
endure so i'm gonna also have to go with
the fruit one for that one
yeah uh someone wants to know what oh go
ahead i would just say at the very least
i could wear an adult diaper
if i really wanted an orange 100 and uh
in this pandemic you don't have to be
around anyone so
you can be sitting on your toilet and
doing work all day long if you need to
there you go
uh someone to know what's your favorite
song at the moment
oh and oh i'm gonna add on to that what
is a dream
musical collaboration for you oh
uh
[Laughter]
jeez a dream okay favorite song right
now
i've been listening to a lot of like
cynthia
sort of like chill 80s inspired like
gemini drive
okay because um i don't think anybody's
ever heard of that spotify just
makes my daily mix and i'm like i like
that
later i'll check it and i'll be like oh
okay that's what they're called
very cool uh and uh
emil rockmeyer is also
an artist that i've been really
listening to a lot um same
like chill cynthia kind of uh
but in terms of a dream musical
collaboration
uh i would love
to and i don't know it's only because i
l
listen this is the age that we live in
right now i have to i have to couch this
in a thousand
like parentheticals i don't know
anything about how this band
is if any of them are dead if any of
them are racist
i only just listen to their music
potential problematic
stuff aside yes so the band the fix from
the 80s
i would love to collaborate with for
some reason i just feel like it's such a
they're so strange and cool cool
uh yeah and if they're alive i mean
sounds like it
could be a possibility a reality hell
yeah
for you um okay this is a great question
uh what video game would you recommend
to get people into video games
a tetris oh yeah i love tetris i'm not a
gamer but that's all i played on like an
old-school
janky computer when i was in high school
i would argue it's the best video game
of all time
i just saw your song about the straight
piece being the best piece in tetris
and uh yeah i understood that i was like
okay
he's not totally out of my realm of
understanding games
i get that well yeah i mean with those
star bomb songs it's all about like
come up with a gag that's really like
easy for
for it's easy to like hammer yeah
exactly
totally uh oh someone wants to know what
is the worst thing that you've ever been
paid
to draw or say in a voiceover
oh uh
and you can also if you don't want to be
negative you can switch this and say the
best thing
that you've been paid to draw or say in
a voiceover but entirely
for some reason my voice my mind goes to
um really early on i got a i got a job
doing a voice role for
um a uh in like an iphone game
okay um called a mini gore so the main
character was named john gore it was
like this and he talked like this all
the time
fun so being like a young
inexperienced voice actor uh doing that
voice and like screaming
and just for hours and i'm just like
yeah i can do it whatever i'm
[ __ ] like i'm invincible yeah
but so i did that and i was like man
that was that was tough
and and so after i did that you know i
went on my computer and like quietly
edited it for
you know an hour or two um and then sent
it off
and then i you know i went to the
bathroom and i walked in front of the
mirror
and i like opened my mouth and just like
say something or do
a voice or something and nothing came
out
was like oh i legitimately just lost my
voice
and this has never happened to me before
um so like for the rest of the night
i couldn't say a damn thing wow yeah you
shredded your vocal cords
yeah do you do any um
like voice preservation on a regular
basis like do you do the celine dion
i'm not talking for 24 hours before a
performance kind of thing
um sometimes
because there is like there's a quality
of like
gravel that comes to the voice when you
like use it for a good hour
um so if i know like that i'm going to
record where the character needs to be a
little like nasally or a little gravelly
i'll just you know talk to myself in the
car
while i'm away there just to sort of
like get it warmed up but like i don't
do any
i don't do any like you know
right right right sizes rubber baby
buggy bumper
yeah all of them i for some reason i've
just
been able to go with it i just the pipes
are
just very solid at this point
uh okay someone wants to know what song
did you have to hit the dance floor to
at your middle school dance
i did never i was not that kid i never
went to those
i did not do those never ever
there you go i'm glad that middle school
just the phrase middle school dance has
us all going ah
no thank you i don't even know if i had
a middle school dance like i
can't remember oh uh where'd you grow up
florida yeah oh you for sure
had some kind of crazy middle school
dance in florida
uh oh okay here's an interesting
question what does aaron feel
uh it holds for the future of arts and
communications
uh and if he has any ideas or plans for
the future of game grumps in the long
term
what was that first question what do you
feel it holds for the future of arts and
communications i'm gonna
hone this in a little bit what do you
think
the future of youtube animation
holds if you have any predictions on it
i know it's
kind of wild to see into the future in
that sense but if you have like i mean
it's been a wild ride in that
genre i feel like till now do you have
any ideas where it's going
um
or is it just kind of unpredictable and
you're kind of riding the wave as you
see it developing
well it's i mean it's like it's making
all these things like fire so i'm like
trying to organize it
um i
i think what we're seeing happen
you know if if i can compare like early
youtube to now is
we're seeing like much bigger
production in in a lot of stuff right um
and i think it's become even more clear
uh during this time
because so many of us myself included
like we had a show that was
very produced right like we would go
into the office we had a stage and we
had lights and we have a director
and um and we we basically put that show
on hiatus because we can't do it from
home
right it just it just can't be like how
it was
um but i think that's something
that is going to be much huger because
now
you know in the early days of youtube
monetization was all about
you know those automatic ad revenue
things but now
it's you're seeing almost in every video
now there's a sponsorship
right yes there's a um because that's
reliable
right you know if i release a video
you know once a month twice a month
whatever i'm going to make x amount of
dollars
and then i can use x amount of dollars
to pay a production team do this level
of production et cetera
so i think i think the consistency that
comes with that
um that sort of model uh is going to
drive
more like consistently produced content
um because so much of the appeal in
early youtube was just like
it's just a bunch of kids with cameras
bad like where else are you gonna see
this
yeah um yeah but nowadays it's like you
still have that ability to be like this
is the show that i want to make
um but i'm competing with so many other
people now
right and you know at the very end of
the day
people still want to see good audio
quality
like good editing um so like i find
myself watching now like
channels that are sort of in between
it's like it's it's
a girl or a dude or whoever who's
like this is my show and this is what i
do but clearly
they know lighting they know how to like
set up cameras and stuff it's very fluid
and it has that that it still has like a
homemade feel but at the same time it's
like
oh this is clearly not just like hey i'm
here and i'm recording it's
like i set up the camera here
professionalism to it yeah exactly
um so i think the future is somewhere in
between because there's always going to
be the big studios that make like the
huge
production things yeah but then you're
gonna have the philip defrancos that
like
you know it's very produced but also
it's just a dude in the camera and a set
and at the very end of the day that's
you know that's how it feels more
intimate yeah
no that's uh it's interesting i've been
gathering that kind of information from
a lot of people and it seems to be all
kind of tracking the same way that the
authenticity-ish
of someone seemingly doing their own
production
is still what people want to watch even
if
you know behind the scenes there's 10
people off camera
helping it look like a one-person show
situation i think there's a sweet spot
between like
fluff and because if you watch like a
good morning america or something it's
just like there's so much fluff
and like stuff to get through and i feel
like content
on youtube is targeted it's like i'm
watching this video because of
x thing right like it's not it's not
like this show that has to appeal to
everyone it's like no this is
a news show we tell the news in the
first
minute like and and we're done you know
like if you want a recipe
the recipe starts at the 30-second mark
you know like
it's very targeted as opposed to just
it's a production whatever
yeah ah that's interesting very i thank
you for those insightful thoughts those
are very helpful
uh okay last question what has kept you
motivated in the eight years that you've
done
game grumps um
just that it's fun i mean it's
like i'd figure something else out to do
if it wasn't fun
yeah um you know at times you know
there's parts of
when i talk about that i mean doing the
show right like
at the end of the day if i decided to
like walk away from it all i'd probably
still do
the game grumps show um with dan we just
sit down and we play games and it's fun
um the the hard part is like the
the boss stuff the meetings and the
decision makings and the
running a company yeah yeah exactly
um so that i think that's what keeps it
going is that it's
it's fun if it wasn't fun i would i'm
not the kind of person that would just
do it because like
push through yeah it makes me money and
it's my living or what it's like i would
come up with something else
that's much more fun um i mean that's
how
game reps came to you was just i was
already
fine um with what i was doing before
that and it was just like this is fun i
want to keep exploring this
that's great i also think for your
audience that's like so reassuring
that they know that you're having fun
doing it that they can rely on the fact
that you're
the content gets made because you enjoy
it and and i think
and we've sort of been honest about that
you know it's
obviously like if i'm like everybody has
days where it's like
[ __ ] all screw i don't want to do
this yeah
i'm going back to school i'm going to be
an accountant i don't know
but but like you know publicly it's like
people know like ah man you know i'm in
a weird spot right now
um we try to be sort of open about that
stuff and
you know lately it's been awesome we
recently did a format change for
we put out like 10 minute episodes
before and now we're doing like 30
minute episodes
cool and just that little change um
really just like rekindled so it's just
a completely different relationship now
where we don't have to like stop and
start all the time
that it makes it so much more enjoyable
that's great and it's also
nice for you to like pivot shift a
little bit get something that reignites
what the core was of making this content
to begin with
like that i think is so important
because the audience knows when you're
faking it the audience knows when you're
lying through your teeth that it's you
can't get one over on them so it's
important that you connect
with what you're doing uh yeah
absolutely this has been super fun
before we wrap up completely
usually when we do the podcast in person
we gift
our guest a fortune cookie personalized
for being here but
um because we're doing it digitally we
have a digital fortune cookie that i
believe has been sent to you
wonderful if you're able to read that
out loud
for everyone that would be so lovely
okey doke
uh i've got a beautiful little image
right here of a fortune cookie and when
i scroll down it cracks open
surprise you're not the only one that
can do animation
so here is here is
my fortune which is very long and i
don't know if any printer would be able
to
yeah it's a bit wordy uh this isn't
exactly a fortune but a way to make sure
you are aware of the following book
review by ron cox on goodreads this is
for
uh our book uh ghost hunter's adventure
club in the secret of the grand chateau
written by my uncle dr cecil h mills
who i absolutely hate uh yeah we haven't
even had a chance to talk about that
other thing that uh happens in your
world which is writing novels
occasionally so that was my uncle though
i
i didn't have anything to do with that
he just wanted me to promote it my mom
wanted me to promote
it fair fair fair um the review reads
thank god for the coronavirus okay
starting off with a bang
it forced me to relax and listen to my
son as he read aloud parts of this book
hilarious oh thank god the virus has
lasted long enough to finish this book
i feel like there's a lot more going on
than that but okay lots of fun
starting with the cover that looks like
a hearty boy nancy drew addition to the
letter to
the letters from the readers please dr
cecil h mills graces with another book
soon
that is very sweet and i will pass it on
to my horrible uncle who i hate
oh wonder well hopefully your horrible
uncle has some writing
in his uh in his future um erin where
can people find
everything that you are doing if they
don't already know
um gamegrumps is youtube.com gamegrumps
go check it out that's our gaming
channel
um if you want to check out the book
ghost hunters adventure club at the
secret of grand chateau
uh that is available anywhere books are
sold um and
audiobook just released and you can get
that
banned camp i believe read by your uncle
yes he narrated it even though he has a
voice actor
nephew who loves working uh he decided
to narrate it on his own
dick yeah um and then
uh soviet jump game is available on
steam and it's absolutely free you can
just download it and play it
that's amazing yeah it's uh it's battle
royale so you know we want as many
people on there as possible so
take it play it it's fun it's a whole
game there's no like
pay to win stuff it's just play it it's
awesome
very cool well thank you for this lovely
conversation i've learned a lot
and i have to go now i want to go
download tetris again
and just rekindle my love for that guys
make sure you check out everything that
this man
is up to he is has no shortage of
artistic endeavors for you to enjoy
thank you again so much for the
conversation we'll see you guys next
time on not too deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep not too deep
with christ
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry
and an extra special thanks to flula for
the theme music